let me ask you about mentorship you said
uh teachers and mentors you had
mentors what's a good Mentor for you
harsh or supportive supportive
supportive you seen Whiplash the movie
so that guy like somebody screaming at
you like kicking you off the cliff not
necessary I feel like anybody that's
truly passionate about something that
they want to be great at or a master of
or this and that they've already got
that person inside their own head you
you don't need somebody else to do that
for you I think you need love acceptance
guidance support
time
um advice if you ask for it just a space
just a nice open space all my mentors
were just that for me they didn't tell
me to do anything they they didn't care
like it cuz they're not they why do they
need to be invested in where I'm going
only I know where I'm going so for some
mentor to come and be like this is what
you need to be doing and practice this
it's like but why what if that's not my
path that might be your path so I'm not
really again otherwise it feels like a
sport like who can run the fastest race
and it's like well okay well I get that
for that for sport maybe it makes sense
to have someone a bit more hardcore but
still like I would say athletes have the
same mentality they've got they've got
that in them already too like so I think
more like of a strategic approach to
mentorship works really well and mainly
just have having an open space and just
being available to someone MH and kind
of show that you they see the special in
you and they give you the room to
develop that special whatever exactly
cuz if you do have that harsh critic
inside you it's like it is nice to have
somebody that isn't like your family or
someone that's not obligated any way
that just sees your talent and they're
like yeah I dig what you're doing keep
doing
it yeah it's funny that that's not
always easy to come by do you have any
mentors yeah I've had a few recently but
for most of my life people didn't
really you know I I'm very much like
that too like somebody to pet me on the
back and say like like see something in
you of
value um yeah I didn't really have
that so do you wish you did yeah yeah
but maybe the wishing that I did is the
thing that made me who I am not having
it the longing for that maybe that's the
thing that um helped me
develop a constant sense of longing
which I
think it's it's a is a way of because I
have that engine in me it really allows
me to deeply appreciate every single
moment every single everything that's
given to me so like just a Eternal
gratitude so you never know which the
which are the bad parts and the good
parts so if you remove one thing it
might
be it uh the whole thing might collapse
I suppose I'm grateful for the whole
thing that one note you screwed up so
many years ago that might have been
essential what about because you do
Jiu-Jitsu yes so like do you are you I
don't my dad does my dad's super into it
I love my dad he's the ghost um but no I
don't do it he's a he's a blue belt
right now nice nice you ever been on the
mat with him like not yet but I plan on
it should do it what belt are you black
belt sick do you want to go on yeah
right you got the talking part of
you just down you have to do the the
technique um but like for that like for
instance like do
you do you need a harsh Mentor or
teacher or yeah but you like you said it
really beautifully like there's a to to
me I agree there's a difference between
Sport and art yeah they overlap there's
you know for sure but there's something
about sport where like Perfection is
actually like Perfection Perfection is
really the thing you really want to get
to the technical Perfection with art it
feels like technical Perfection
is um is almost a way to get
lost on the path to wherever something
unique
so um but yeah with with sport I
definitely and one of the kind of
athletes that loves to have like a
dictatorial
coach yeah somebody that like helps me
really push myself to the Limit but
you're the one that's kind of dictating
how hard you're getting pushed in a way
like you're choosing your Mentor like
that Whiplash video is like he didn't
ask for that you know in a way he might
have well maybe maybe subconsciously I
mean there's it's a movie
so next you're going to tell me they're
just actors I mean and but you know yeah
how do we choose things you know you
don't always choose but you you're kind
of maybe subconsciously
choose and and some of it like some of
the great Olympic athletes I've
interacted with their parents for many
years would forced them to go to
practice until they discovered the
beauty of the thing that they were doing
and then they loved it yeah so like at
which point does uh something that looks
like abuse become like a gift you know
it's
weird it's all very weird but for
you support and
space to discover the thing The Voice
the music within you person personal
choice because I'm very familiar with
the inner critic and I can bring her out
at any point I don't need help with that
you know Al so you do have she call she
was on overdrive that's why now I'm I
had to work on that so much yeah you
have a really happy way about you right
now thanks the very
Zen
I